[Musique]
une journée pour échanger les idées les
expériences et trouver des pistes
d'action pour prévenir et lutter contre
la pauvreté
c'était l'ambition portée par tous ces
participants de la deuxième conférence
régionale des acteurs des idées viennent
parce qu on a mixé les approches mixer
les publics là qui sont autour de la
table avec des personnes de la société
civile est demandeur d'emploi des
acteurs institutionnels associatifs
donc effectivement il ya des belles
idées qui qui vont jaillir et qui vont
se mettre en oeuvre sous forme d'actions
d'amélioration du dispositif une
intelligence collective et participative
au service de la cohésion sociale
les élus ont rappelé les actions déjà
effective comme la création de 400
places de crèches supplémentaires
la mise en place d'un parcours de
formation pour les jeunes de 16 à 18 ans
un plan sans abri et les petits
déjeuners gratuits dans les écoles mais
des actions sont encore à établir pour
répondre à l'urgence la stratégie de
prévention afin de contrer la pauvreté
ça réinvestissement majeur est important
de 8 5 milliards d'euros dans nos
politiques d'insertion et nos politiques
pour aider et lutter contre la pauvreté
je peux vous donner quelques exemples
quand on augmente le minimum vieillesse
est à ce point que touchent les
personnes âgées qui était de l'or un peu
inquiété inférieur à 800 euros qu on le
passe à 900 euros c'est une augmentation
de 11% quand on augmente la location au
rallye dans les capés de 11% et aussi
pour l'augmenter pour le maintenir à et
le faire remonter à 900 euros sont des
publics qui potentiellement ne retrouve
pas travailler soit au titre de leur
handicap sous titre de l'ach de l'âge on
est conscient on augmente c'est minime 1
ces minima qui sont importants et sur
lequel il était de fait inférieure au
seuil de pauvreté qu'on leur donne les
moyens pour pouvoir vivre mieux et
dignement à la réunion 38% de la
population vit en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
le département lance un grand projet de
service public de l'insertion retenus au
niveau national pour prévenir et lutter
contre la pauvreté sur notre territoire
[Musique]